hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tara Jessa and tonight I
went and saw Slenderman he's a nice guy
I've met him
mr. Slenderman bring me a quick death
boom boom boom boom give kick capture me
in the forest and look like tree bum bum
bum bah there are gonna be spoilers in
this reaction I didn't love this film so
I'm just gonna spoil the crap there were
some fun moments overall it was just
kind of meh not predictable what's the
word I want to use expected I guess
there's some really cool attempts made
to make something awesome and badass and
scary and it was ruined by effects that
they use that were so weird and
lackluster and then also the dialogue
the the script the writing it left a lot
to be desired I truly thought the acting
was was really good I enjoyed the girl
gang and weirdly I'm a super notice the
lighting was good I don't think I've
ever noticed lighting before but there's
also some weird like face things that
happen there's one scene where two
characters are making out and the
character that seen Slenderman is on the
bottom and the character who hasn't is
on the top and the character who has it
just starts freaking out and like
shaking violently and making crazy
noises and it was very loud which is
startling but it was also the effects
looked good at all so not one of the
theater quite knew how to react to it is
this scary or is it just loud is this
scary or is it just loud it's probably a
question that my cats ask all the time I
just started laughing though because it
was so uncomfortable because I think it
was bad I just I still can't really tell
these are really rattling a lot
they have Taric cards on them but is it
worth it no I also really really
hated the amount of horror cliches that
this movie brought up I felt like we had
gotten past using every horror cliche in
the book but apparently we haven't
because Slenderman just they keep coming
like I said earlier they're making out
have you never seen a horror film you
don't make out in horror films or you're
gonna die she's spoilers she became a
tree there's also the cliché of alright
everyone keep your blindfolds on and
immediately one of them takes a
blindfold off Chloe what's the actual
come on Chloe another one is that two of
the four of the friends have been taken
they're just gone and one of them is
seriously freaking out and the fourth is
just like this isn't real you guys it's
all in our heads what how is it not real
your friends are taken and your other
friend is like freaking out your she
actually she's had seen things at this
point she's still like no I don't think
it's real and it's I understand like
maybe she's going through denial she's a
high schooler who can't cope with things
I understand that I've been there
definitely was there but it just it
plays off it's just like no no it's
uninteresting and it's stupid and it
makes me not like that character I don't
know if this is just me but recently
I've seen an influx of horror films
using current technology which
absolutely makes sense
it ruins the magic of a horror film for
me first for some reason it never it
feels authentic
maybe it's because I'm on my damn cell
phone 24/7 or because I spend so much
time online
I am a youtuber and I I don't know I I
guess I'm very well-versed in the world
I feel like a lot of us are it feels a
little not it just doesn't feel genuine
but this one starts off and they summon
Slenderman by watching a video where you
then summon him you watch the video and
he summoned he has been some ended he's
hidden some IFFT if you will it doesn't
work because then everyone would watch
it and then everyone would be taken by
Slenderman and then there would be no
one for slender to man anymore
everyone would be gone they'd all be
taken liam neeson would have
a field day they kind of play at that at
the end of trick or treat or trick or
treat truth or dare when she's like you
know what to save my friend I'm gonna
give it to the world and then she makes
a youtube video and everyone is now in
the truth or dare
world but with this it's like how is
every high school student not taken by
Slenderman because when any of that
stuff happens every single student just
jumps on it because it's fun and it's
stupid shit that you do with your
friends
I still remember in middle school they
told us about Bloody Mary is that her
name where's that that's the drink oh
yes bloody mary bloody mary is a
folklore legend consisting of a ghost a
phantom and is said to appear in a
mirror when the name is chanted
repeatedly and as a delicious beverage
that you consume usually during brunch
usually after a night of consuming other
delicious beverages and you just need to
like keep it going not that I've been
there Oh
in middle school we all did Bloody Mary
you know like it just it spreads around
high school everyone would do it that's
the biggest thing is that these four
girls are the only one in this high
school that have done it that's not
believable at all so these high school
girls are hanging out and they're
drinking vodka they're watching porn and
they're summoning Slenderman in high
school I was just belting out lame is
24/7 and eating too much pasta you know
what I mean maybe you don't I think the
most interesting thing for me to do
during this film was to look throughout
the trees and try to spot Slenderman and
in my opinion they didn't utilize that
at all that's like what I think about
what I think about Slenderman is him in
trees obviously they did this in
hereditary this was no hereditary they
also do this in the conjuring this was
also no conjuring but in those films you
would be watching and then at like three
minutes into a scene you would notice
something that's been there the whole
time and it just doesn't move and it's
just there to scare the shit out of you
and this should have used that so much
that should have been the biggest
portion of scares in this film in my
opinion and they fairly did it at all
like they did it really you always were
like well he's obviously here right now
because this is the music is amped up
but like he's supposed to be it was
never freaked out by the foreign scenes
and that is such a disappointment
oh another cliche is the first girl to
go missing shows up and is in the
shadows of one of the girls houses and
she starts whispering follow me Evelyn
or whatever it's not her name but she
follow me Evelyn
and she's like what did you you have
been missing and she's like follow me
and she goes away and it's like well
your dead friend is in the shadows
calling you into the forest don't follow
her you all deserve to be taken by
Slenderman Jesus they also had a lot of
quick fast shot sequences that like one
of the characters were freaking out and
all these different shots were coming up
and it was compelling until they would
ruin it by putting like stock footage of
like earthworms in there the thing like
really lame and they did that so many
times like six times you got the same
stock footage and it was part of what
was in the video that they watched a7
slimmer slender man so that makes sense
but it wasn't a good video in the first
place if you're gonna have a viral video
that summoning Slenderman make it a
scary video and I wasn't at all afraid
of the video I just wrote where the his
runs mom no follow up so you see the
movie you'll know one thing that I
really enjoyed about the script let's be
honest the only thing that I enjoyed
about this script is they're walking
through the hallways at the very
beginning of the movie all four girls
they're like what age would you like to
be stuck in for your whole life and one
of them is like 21 one of them is like
30 the other is 10 I don't know why you
would choose 10 but the other is like I
would like to be this age if we can all
live together forever and I was like
well that's a boring bit of dialogue
that we didn't need but they all four
died and I wonder if it was pointing
towards them being together at the end
though you literally see one of them
turn into a tree so I don't imagine
they're together but I did find that
that was I think meant to be on purpose
but that's all I got was the skirt I
haven't raged at a film like this in a
while like I raged it like Mamma Mia - I
was not at all a passionate
me too but I love horror and I wanted
this to be so so good and so I wouldn't
recommend seeing this in theaters I
don't think if you want to see it
definitely check it out
rent it though buy it on Amazon for
three bucks honestly if you want a cool
Slender Man story there is a story
series on no sleep which is a subreddit
and it's my favorite place to go if you
are ever looking for horror stuff go to
the subreddit no sleep and just click
there top of all time and like you'll
have 30 insanely good original stories
and in there somewhere is a Slenderman
type story that is killer about these
people who go up into the mountains to
go skiing and get stuck there and then
there's Slenderman in the forest thank
you so much for watching
me just rain it was honestly very fun I
really enjoy raging the hilarious thing
for me to say like five foot Tamron I
really enjoy raging thanks for watching
I'll see you guys next week
[Music]